who here's remember the marshmallow test
so they've got the two kids one kid gets
two marshmallows versus one marshmallow
if they win right there's like the
obvious binary example but you can run a
third test on this which is how long do
I move the marshmallow out do I move the
second marshmallow out an hour do I move
it out a week so the people that can do
the doing without seeing the results
that they're doing for an extended
period of time the longer you're able to
do that the more successful you will be
period if there is a single trait that
any person wants to develop it is the
ability to weather short-term discomfort
for long-term achievements making the
short-term trade it's just paid so many
dividends in my life and it's been so
hard for me it's hard being the person
that you want to be his heart and it
doesn't feel easy it's just doing it
anyways knowing that you don't feel that
way and a lot of times in decisions is
saying no that feels exciting